fortnight lifestream draws in more than
1 million viewers
Drake sets record with his fortnight
twit GPU fortnight holds the record for
the most videos related to a video game
uploaded in a single month two hundred
thousand viewers vs. 20 thousand they're
getting paid they're getting paid to
play for fight they're gonna bang for it
YouTube gaming it's all for tonight it's
all I'm here beautiful it's PewDiePie
I'm here to talk about my favourite
video game of all time for at night I
love this game so fun you know what I
look for in a game no no no go away
that's why I prefer their a ripoff of
the game that's my favorite rush oh
sorry I meant the ripoff of the ripoff
of the ripoff of the ripoff of the
ripoff of the ripoff of a game now
that's what I call original content for
tonight it's just everywhere lately and
I think I'm the only one I'm the only
one left that hasn't played it so today
I thought we're going to play oh wow
look it looks like we're gonna win it
just gotta keep a building which is what
this game is all about apparently
[Music]
where is the other guy oh there he is
ah Jesus I don't know if I could do this
oh I did it yeah yeah I did it
oh sorry I didn't realize I had to play
the game way I have to play the game
myself and not just react to
pre-recorded footage that someone else
did instead we are going to react to
some for tonight cringe everybody that's
right I am better than everyone else so
I get to do this I am just joking of
course I'm not gonna play for tonight
what do you think I'm so pathetic beta
male that's right wait instead of going
to laugh at people playing for night
starting off with my favorite fortnight
channel ali-a this is capitalism at its
finest look at this my god it's all for
nothing it's a lot of arrows and there's
a lot of fortnight's and you gotta
appreciate it Jesus Christ dude I
especially like this one you know here's
a regular video with an interesting
concept 200,000 views right next to it
where's fortnight Battle Royale player
ever funny 5 million views I think the
main thing I learned about this is the
color there's a lot of shiny color here
I feel like if I took one of my regular
thumbnails this is garbage
it needs way more hue on it let's see
here
there you go that looks much better I
think this is how I will do all my
thumbnails from now on you got to get
the kids to watch you that's how you do
it you just increase that huge
saturation slider and you got the kids
watching what's the number 2 thing
that's right the intros
you gotta bait the kids in alright
they're not just gonna watch some
10-minute video unless you have some
bait going on so you gotta have
something mildly interesting happening
and then just roll the intro
yo look at that if you want to find out
what's over there watch the whole ten
minute video guys it's pretty epic this
rule applies to all youtubers but I
think I think le a does is the finest
these guys are trying to steal my
secretive spot I do not think so guys
[Music]
what's he gonna do
guess I'll have to watch 34 minutes to
find out this doesn't apply to just
ali-a the this formula literally applies
to every single fortnight's dreamer
youtuber ever well ever sorry of
legendary so dick okay now we just be
doing the game guys oh my god what
what's he doing why we're down to the
top 10 oh my god how did I kill him who
7 people alive
[Music]
Brad inside why don't I have a cool
flashy intro like all the other called
you fortnight's youtubers make one
please now otherwise I'm gonna be super
angry where is the other guy oh there he
is
oh Jesus I don't know if I could do this
that was epic why would I call intro
alia has the best interest it's the most
crazy base of everything made this is
actually insane oh my god wait one game
I have never experienced that in my life
it's like when we're not just click
baiting the click babe we gotta click
bait the actual content by now it's
really how far is it's gonna go at the
end of the day a little just be no
content whatsoever just click bait out
of clickbait like just keep watching
guys well I think this kind of reminds
him of TV isn't that what they do for
the Oh stay tuned after the commercials
we have an important announcement and
then you walk through the commercial
there's never something important oh my
god I just discovered that TV is a lie
I'm so woke well we're heading there
we're heading there that's for sure
if anything I should just start click
baiting my minerals so that you guys
will keep watching through the mid roll
guys sorry we got to take a commercial
mid roll here
but after this video as the commercial
there's something there there is
something there it's easy for children
to draw with Naji draw they draw in the
party put in the positioning points and
build out the picture nettie draw and
junior magic or the exciting way to draw
please
[Music]
that's a swear that's a swear in the
intro what what the Frick man I've been
trying to censor my swears for the
freakin longest time and he just gets
away this space there's better not this
best not be monetized I'm gonna get so
angry I'm tired of this I'm tired of you
to see Paul Kersey
this is favor ISM stupid alright let's
see the dance then let's see the dance
I'm doing the fort night dances we're
getting boys guys what we get to come to
[Music]
buddy 9 million views I am NOT salty by
the way if you think I'm criticizing
these 4 9 youtubers because I am jealous
that they're getting millions of views
then you are mistaken
I am NOT solo okay I get a lot of use -
and they're all monetized - trust me I
got a ton of ads rolling on my videos
welcome everyone my name's Ali a this
gameplay is not only one of my luckiest
but also how is a playing game if his
hand is up here this is faker stupid
faker dick now is no one realized this
this is ridiculous no for real
Ali he's found his niche and he's doing
what he's enjoying so why shouldn't he
alright it's all like I just benefited
from happy wheels back in the day where
you could literally put zero effort into
the videos and still get millions of
viewers and I keep looking back into
those days and thinking man things were
so much better I could just upload 10
minute uncut footage I miss still
YouTube guys can we just bring back old
YouTube I don't understand this just
like why for at night out of all games
did fortnight have to become the popular
one my second favorite fortnight you to
raise goes ninja and
he's also the master of the intro let's
just watch listen to here and today I'm
super excited if we bring you guys this
video and talk to you about the brand
new hey guys today's gizumon here and I
am so excited as you can tell by the
tone of my voice and now I'm going to
proceed to tell you about a giveaway so
be sure to leave a like a subscribe and
please before we get into today's video
I want to do another freebie bug
giveaway for all of my subscribers so as
you guys know there's brand new weekly
items here in fortnight and they're
super cool and they're a part of the
this was giving away this for free isn't
that crazy that's crazy
he must love us so much valentine's
update so if you guys want to win some
freebie books here on today's video all
you guys gotta do is drop a like and for
every single like we get on today's
video i'll do 5 e bug so if we get 2,000
likes I'll do $100 freebie bucket away
from all my scam so me this means he
really loves his subscribers because
he's spending money on them it's like
we're his main side chick and he wants
to just give us stuff I love it which
includes a holster giveaway in that now
in today's Lisa giveaway giveaway doing
a giveaway giving back to subscribers
and hooking size guys up with these
packs for every 500 likes we get here on
today's video will equal one starter
pack so if you guys have not already
dropped like on the video make sure to
subscribe with that post notification
about turned on it and comment down
below letting me know that you guys want
this what am I gonna do okay
all the steps just comment down below
starter pack rogue skin free V bucks
some I'm telling you tube more and more
and more it's just about manipulating
kids this is what this is I like this
video because he's somewhat self-aware
about his whole giveaway stick so hit
that like button subscribe to the
channel if you're brand new hit that
notification about I'm just kidding
that's just [ __ ] cringe oh now it's
cringe okay yeah no you're right
definitely wasn't cringe before top five
youtubers who have sworn I would never
swear because I have raw notes
I do the Minecraft sound so you can
trust to never get a swear in my video
isn't that right YouTube today
we're gonna be going over five fortnight
youtubers who sworn number five
oh come on come on with the Frick guys
that's not funny
my third favorite youtuber of course is
Jake Paul but I subscribed to him for
his gaming content that's what I truly
enjoy and the girlfriend fortnight
distraction challenge there's no way
this is monetized this is clearly sexual
content in the thumbnail if I put
anything near this it will 100% be to
monetize that's fine that's fine that's
fine
my favorite video of Jake Paul playing
for nine is when he isn't actually
playing for nine he's is donating two
hundred thousand to his favorite twitch
streamer a lot of people seem to think
that I'm some sort of poll expert at
this point and they asked me like oh so
did you hear about him actually donating
two hundred thousand I'm like no listen
you didn't even had spent two seconds on
this video to understand that he's just
donating it to his friend and his friend
is just setting it up it's so easy to
set up these notifications saying oh you
this person donated this obviously
hidden giveaway two hundred thousand
he's manipulating clickbait it doesn't
matter
this is copying mr. B's video where he
donated thirty thousand to ninja he's
copying rice gum who did the whole
sexual thing with the girls with a sone
girlfriend it's really fun to see just
people coming up with fun and original
ideas what am I talking about at least I
don't play fortnight that's pretty much
the only thing I have going for me it's
my my biggest pride and demise at the
same time let's check out one of these
rice cam videos that apparently gets
over 10 million views Jesus Christ one
kill equals one remove clothing cuz it
doesn't make sense cuz normal youtubers
if you don't host video this is so
clearly someone else's footage that he's
reacting to this is monetize there's no
way this is monetized at least fine he
gets ten million views with their sexual
clickbait
why do I even upload YouTube why do I
even try with him finding out I gotta
watch the full video to see the titties
I actually know a secret way to get to
the end of the video quicker you just
have to click over here guys I don't
know if you noticed it there's no way
this is monetized this is no way there's
no way there's a sonic town and I don't
want the world to see me because I don't
think that they understand you may think
oh he's your salty that's not it at all
I am glad for all these youtubers making
this great stuff that they've they'll
enjoy everyone should be free to do what
they like and have fun at the process
and not just make a lot of money that I
would like instead so anyway guys please
leave a like on this video for every 5
likes I will give away a 5 like myself
all you gotta do is subscribe hit the
bell and leave 5 likes and comment 5
likes and you will find out what is over
there guys check out next video and I
see you guys bye
[Music]